now they've worked overtime to deny
obscure and deflect the truth but
democrats are conspiring with an array
of activists and business leaders on
plans that are already well underway
now more significant than that obscene
3.5 trillion dollar grab bag these two
unofficial policies will weaken and
change america forever
simply stated this stealth agenda
includes maintaining open borders
and surrendering to china
the activists think america is evil that
we're living on stolen land and they
want to get as many new democrat voters
in here as quickly as possible
and then there's the donor class who
always love cheap labor
never fans of immigration enforcement
they prefer the free flow of goods and
services and they don't care how it
affects any of the little people they
never have
and as for china the biden
administration's concern for human
rights totally out the window they're
happy to ignore cruel deprivations of
basic rights to dissent worship a fair
trial etc so long as the ccp makes some
i don't know unenforceable pledge on
climate change
save the planet but let those uyghurs
die
and with these dupes in the white house
there isn't a top investment bank or
multinational in the world that would
think of steering money away from china
why bother
the sad fact is by the end of biden's
two years first two years in office
america will be home to several million
more migrants
and hundreds of thousands of refugees
and as we obsess over our diversity and
newfound multiculturalism
china will have likely grown a lot more
powerful than america both economically
and militarily
now don't get deceived one every now and
then for political expediency sake the
biden team will take action that seems
to run counter to their agenda like
deporting some haitians new york times
will even write about it
but that's all for show
how many have been released into the u.s
uh they're released on conditions and
approximately i think it's about 10
000 or so 12 000 have been released yes
and of the 5 000 that are still in
process we will make determinations
whether they will be uh returned
uh to uh haiti uh based on our public
health and public interest uh
authorities
so what we talk about a total of 12 000
or could it be even higher it could it
could be even higher
i wouldn't buy a car from that guy he's
lying when he says it could be higher no
mr secretary it will be higher
exponentially higher
by ditching most all of trump's
effective enforcement tools at the
border the biden administration sent a
message to the world that our border is
de facto open
now local media in south and central
america is running ads hawking passage
for anyone who wants to cross into
america the cost is anywhere from seven
to ten thousand dollars now which they
can pay off in installments while
they're working here
illegally now these are economic
migrants they're not legitimate asylum
seekers
but there is literally zero deterrence
from the bible administration in fact
they want this to continue
new voters and cheap labor it's a
win-win for democrats
why didn't you build
forgive me a wall or a fence to stop
them from walking in this flood of
people coming across the dam is this
paul the policy of this administration
we do not agree with the building of the
wall the law provides that individuals
can make a claim for humanitarian relief
that is actually one of our proudest
traditions
can you believe this guy
he's proud of what they're doing down
there on the border
it's disgusting
then again dhs secretary alejandro
mayorkas himself is kind of a
smooth-talking corruptocrat who has a
long tradition of working overtime for
the elites who skirt the rules
and now he oversees a bigger scam at the
border
some have argued and there's certainly
in the in the actions that have been
taken a reason to argue that the
administration is loosening enforcement
i don't know that that is the framing
that i would use what i would um
what i would say is we are implementing
um fairness
and justice the statistics of
of your own department show that the
flood of people coming illegally across
the border has gotten worse under the
biden administration so i wouldn't call
it a a flood
it's not a flood i wouldn't frame it
that way but china's watching these
clowns run america into the ground they
see all this happening
and they must be thinking how hard can
it be to eclipse and dominate another
country that loathes itself so much
that it doesn't even think it deserves
a border
or that u.s citizenship is a privilege
not a right
no one in the chinese government is
going to lose much sleep over biden's
posture toward the ccp
they know they already control biden and
his family never forget they already
helped make hunter biden rich
and now they get to toy with john kerry
who just can't stop showering china with
praise over climate change if china
makes a move
and does something positive and
constructive
it's important to recognize that but
it's important to try to sit down to
understand exactly
where the differences are where they may
be able to be bridged
he said that president xi takes this
very personally last week
and thanked him personally it's so
humiliating
forget everything that china has done to
prove itself to be untrustworthy
to conceal the origins of covet 19 we
should have cut off all engagement with
them just at that point
of course crushing dissent making
activists just disappear
none of it matters to the political
elites none of it and certainly not to
our tycoons who see opportunity where
barbarity exists
china spends a lot of resources and
efforts applying the latest digital
technologies in different industries
including the automobile industry making
china a global leader in digitalization
tesla will continue to expand investment
and r d efforts in china i look forward
to meeting you soon and i send my best
wishes to the 2021 world internet
conference
the fact is these ceos are responding to
the political climate here at home
they've watched as our leaders political
military leaders in the u.s have
downplayed the china threat
china is going to eat our lunch
come on man there's no u.s strategy
to try to push back against or be in
conflict with china
china is a rising power that is not to
say however that they are an enemy not a
cut they're not competition for us
if our own government doesn't seem to
care if china does things like threaten
taiwan or slaughters the leaguers
destroys freedom in hong kong then why
should elon musk or tim cook or the head
of goldman sachs for that matter
the most recent example though of
biden's embarrassing capitulation to the
ccp
came in the form of a prisoner swap
china took two businessmen prisoner to
force the u.s to drop its extradition
request of a huawei executive in canada
the white house's chief propagandist
jensaki of course insisted this was all
an uncanny coincidence
i think it's important to note and to be
very clear about this there is no link
it is not it is a we have an independent
justice department we can't determine
how the chinese or others manage their
business over there it's a little bit
different
china's own state-run media outlets have
been bragging nonstop about the party's
deft handling of the matter
the bide administration can spin this
any way they want and they will
but in the real world everyone from
business execs to foreign leaders to
desperate migrants are seeing the truth
america's borders are undefended
and it's returning to its pre-trump
posture of submission to china
once again the world believes that the
future will rise or fall in beijing not
washington
and as long as old joe's in charge
they're probably right and that's the
angle